Hey youtubers it’s charlie and now that
we’ve all had a chance to see Sherlock season
3 it’s time to start talking about season
4 predictions.
So what I’m going to do in this video is
just list my top 10 with as much evidence
as possible for each one.
Before we get started I just got some really
good news and since I’m so happy I’m giving
away a sherlock season 3 dvd to 5 random subscribers
in the comments.
I’ll announce the winners in my next sherlock
Q&A video.
I will continue to do sherlock videos for
the rest of the year, all of my sherlock,
doctor who, game of thrones and walking dead
videos kind of rotate periodically just to
make it easier to focus on stuff when it’s
most relevant.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Carefull for spoilers if you haven’t seen
season 3 yet.
We’ll be talking about some very specific
plot points.
Shall we begin.
Top 10 predictions for season 4.
Number 10 - Watson Baby.
Mary Morstan was super pregnant during the
final moments of his last vow.
So even if season 4 picks up directly after
that, she’s still going to have the baby
in one of those episodes.
I think we can all imagine that at some point
the life of that baby will be threatened by
the villain and sherlock’s last vow will
continue to be a big theme.
Raise your hand if you think that Sherlock
really could be a girl’s name.
Or suggest your favorite watson baby girl
names in the comments.
Number 9 - Sherlock running around with the
watson baby will break the internet.
Tumblr specifically.
Benedict Cumberbatch was the most reblogged
person on tumblr last year.
So imagine what will happen when he starts
clueing for looks with a baby.
Using baby’s in scenes is really hard from
a production stand point.
So don’t expect there to be an actual baby
on screen for a lot of the more intense action
scenes.
But baker street babies is totally going to
be a thing.
I guess you could also consider this a shoutout
to the baker street babes.
They have an awesome sherlock podcast.
Number 8 - Billy Wiggins will be back.
He even called himself Sherlock’s protege.
When he started making deductions in molly’s
lab I actually wondered if there was a connection
between drug addiction and savants.
Or if he was just naturally gifted.
Either way in the canon the Billy and the
Wiggins characters are both really important,
so regardless of which stories they adapt
for each new episode he’ll be there.
In his last vow he kind of took on the collective
role of the homeless network or baker street
irregulars depending on how you view them,
so I’m also wondering if he’s going to
to start running sherlock’s homeless network
too.
Number 7 - Even more mycroft.
This season dealt a lot with Sherlock’s
family, but I don’t expect benedict cumberbatch’s
parents to return.
And if they do have cameos, they will be more
like empty hearse than his last vow.
The Sherlock Mycroft scenes are so popular
in the fandom though and the mycroft character
is so well developed that I think he’ll
continue to be heavily featured.
A big part of their relationship that was
new in season 3 was their childhood.
Learning about redbeard as well as actually
seeing young sherlock.
Played by steven moffat’s real life son.
The next logical step would be to feature
flashbacks to teenage sherlock and mycroft.
In the canon mycroft is about 7 years older
so it would be like teenage sherlock and mycroft
at university.
Quick side note.
If you haven’t seen it yet, Young Sherlock
holmes was an 80s movie that depicted sherlock
during his university years.
The actor that played him Nicholas Rowe is
on Davincis demons now.
Number 6 - Mary will be a much bigger part
of the action.
In his last vow we found out she was an elite
assassin and a deadshot.
So there’s no way season 4 isn’t going
to invoke those skills.
Especially since she’s a mother now.
At this point she’s kind of like Uma Thurman
in Kill Bill.
Someone will probably try to steal baby watson
and sherlock and john will have to stop her
from killing everyone responsible.
I can’t wait to see ninja mary fight scenes.
Someone actually asked me if we’d ever get
to see a sherlock fight scene but we kind
of already did during scandal.
The next logical step would be a mary fight
scene.
We’ve really only seen her sharpshooter
skills.
Number 5 - Sherlock will still be a murderer.
I don’t think that the series will backtrack
on sherlock killing magnussen.
It was a big part of his last vow and taking
that away from him would kind of undo the
sincerity of that promise.
Mycroft’s comment about learning your lesson
is a tip off that there won’t be any major
consequences to sherlock than we’ve already
seen.
I think the government was satisfied with
mycroft’s solution and the season 4 villain
will negate any further concerns.
Number 4 - The stories.
This is a bit of a problem, because they’ve
already done most of Conan Doyle’s best
known stories.
Each season has featured on of his four novels.
And they’ve already done a study in scarlet,
hound of baskerville and sign of four.
So the next logical step is to do Valley of
Fear.
It actually features the first chronological
appearance of moriarty.
It also features sussex villiage.
Remember that place Janine bought the cottage.
In the canon it takes place before rickenback
fall, but if moriarty is back.
This story would make the most sense.
Other stories they could do are Lady Frances
Carfax, Dying Detective and Red Headed League.
Number 3 - A return to proper form.
Steven Moffat said that as sherlock gets more
emotional he becomes less brilliant.
The final moments of his last vow imply that
he’s returning to form.
even if the high functioning sociopath line
is unreliable narration.
In my mind palace the best sherlock holmes
stories are always like chess games.
Very calculated and precise.
So I don’t think we’ll see another episode
like sign of three with sherlock dancing his
way to clues stoned and drunk.
Which kind of implies that the major arc will
have to be something that requires him to
be in proper form.
2 - The final solution.
What better to snap sherlock back into form
than a doomsday scenario set in motion by
the one true moriarty.
Notice I said one true moriarty.
In canon moriarty is every bit as clever as
sherlock.
And if sherlock and mycroft were one step
ahead of moriarty during rikenback fall.
Then wouldn’t it stand to reason that moriarty
would have had his own 13 different solutions.
Regardless of who the villain is, I think
that post credit scene is the signal that
a doomsday scenario has been set in motion.
Like a last will and testament.
and my number 1 prediction - moriarty really
is dead and that clip we saw was being used
by another villain.
Rule number 1 the doctor always lies.
In the world of sherlock different characters
take on the role.
and in this case the mad man in the box is
moriarty inside your television.
With so many other villains to explore it
doesn’t make a lot of sense for Moffat and
Gatiss to retread old territory.Just to be
clear, I definitely think Andrew Scott will
be a part of season 4.
Just not in the way you hope.
I really think it’s just another villain
just enacting Moriarty’s doomsday scenario.
Or enacting their own scenario using him as
a front.
A couple of people it could be including Moriarty’s
brother who’s also named james.
the real colonel moran, henry peter from the
lady carfax story, Rene Heron, Fantomas and
Von Bork.
If it is in fact moriarty, here’s one possible
reason why he’s still alive.
In the story of the final solution we find
out that moriarty’s brother is called james
and the one true moriarty is called professor
moriarty.
That would mean that it was the brother that
killed himself on the rooftop and played the
richard brooke role.
In canon professor moriarty is always someone
who only acts through agents.
It’s a major character trait that he never
directly acts against people, especially sherlock.
And in rikenback and great game he is very
much up in sherlock’s face.
Take that evidence as you will, but let me
know what your biggest prediction is for season
4.
A lot of people have been asking me about
when it’s going to air and unless there
is a major delay in filming, it will be the
same time next year.
They already have the story, the just need
to schedule the actors.
A lot of you guys have requested a moriarty
vid specifically.
So I might do one next week if you guys really
want it.
I’ll probably post my season 4 q&a video
wednesday or thursday.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
I’ll also be doing a new Doctor Who Series
8 Q&A this week.
And details on the weekly walking dead giveaway
I’ll be doing when it comes back.
Right now click here for my breakdown of his
last vow and click here for the q&a.
Thanks so much for watching, see you guys
tonight.
high fives!